despite everything life has thrown at
her
Nikki gubbins just gets on with it
commuting from the Isle of Wight to
Portsmouth for work she believes her
malformations were caused by a drug
called Primrose and she's one of more
than 200 people now preparing to sue the
manufacturer and the government for
failing to protect patients bullied as a
child she says have even more impact
you're funny don't take the time to work
that out
Nikki's mom was given the drug criminals
as a pregnancy test it was made up of
two pills which would induce a period in
women who were not pregnant however many
families believe if the mother was
pregnant it could damage or even kill
their children in the womb the proposed
legal action follows a Sky News
investigation where we found documents
in German archives showing manufacturers
were warned by UK regulators that those
using the drug had an increased risk of
malformations and those records from
that study appeared to have been
deliberately destroyed in order to
frustrate future legal action lawyers
say that early warning signs were
ignored and the drug wasn't tested
before sale
they placed the drug onto the market
without any prior
toxicology testing and I find that quite
astonishing given that this is a
pregnancy test that was given to women
and it had no therapeutic benefit
whatsoever a previous claim by UK
families including Nikki's parents was
abandoned in 1982 and a government
review published in 2017 found that
there was insufficient evidence to show
a causal association between the drug
and birth defects but last year an
Oxford University team produced an
analysis of all the significant studies
relating to perma dose and found the
drug was associated with a doubling of
the risk to an unborn baby it's a hugely
important risk and once you're talking
about the more specific ones like
congenital heart disease neurological
defects ought to double threefold we're
not just saying these individual studies
there's a consistent effect and what
what's interesting is when you look at
the higher quality story if you go old
is even more of an effect a doubling of
the risk is catastrophic recipients of
the legal letters include the UK
government for failure to protect
patients and German pharmaceutical giant
Bayer who now owns shearing the
manufacturer of the drug both say that
the Oxford study has been deemed
unreliable by the European Medicines
Agency and there's been no new evidence
since the previous trial in 1982 Bayer
told Sky News we believe this action to
be without merits and will defend our
position vigorously and if necessary in
court bring it on say campaigners and
then moving forward you sure that the
200-plus alleged victims have waited all
their lives for this if successful the
class action could cost millions in
damages but it's hard to put a price on
a life changed from birth Jason Farrell
Sky News